Thinks Mora. Let's get back to our scatter plot of
friend count versus age. It might be appealing to further
summarize the relationship of age and friend count. Rather than
having the four extra layers of geom line, we could try
to summarize the strength of this relationship in a single
number. Often, analyst will use a correlation coefficient to summarize this,
now, if you're not familiar with correlation, you should review
the links in the instructor notes. We've even included some practice
from Stat 95, that's our statistics course. We're going to
use the Pearson product moment correlation, noted with a
lower case r, to measure the linear relationship between
age and friend count What I want you to
do is to look up the documentation for the
core.test function. Figure out how to find Pearson's r
using any two variables. What's the correlation between age
and friend count? Round your answer to three decimal places.